all right Turtle you were so close Laura
and E.T Canada oh hell yes was I I I
feel like I could taste the 750k but I
walked away with a great experience and
I feel like a million bucks so I have no
complaints I love that positive attitude
um when Monty decided to take Taylor how
what did that feel like how did that how
close did that cut
I mean I loved Monty and even in the
question I asked him in the jury when I
was like why did you not take me and
then expect me to vote for you and he
was like well the final two with Kyle
that was a Fluff answer we already went
over that like a million times me and
Monty I know how irrelevant and he was
just giving an answer and I get that
because that was I guess a tough
question but at the end of the day like
it seems like he would have been a lot
better off because of how better my jury
management was if he had just taken me
seems like he would have won in that
situation because a lot of people were
pissed at me when I sat down in that
jury everyone was like what the hell why
did you play this game like that and I
was like well dude I tried my best and
they were all like oh my God here we go
so um you know I it sucked my heart sank
when I heard it but at the end of the
day if he thought that's what was going
to get him to 750k in order to help his
mom to help his dad I know what he
wanted to do with the money and if he
thought that was the best decision for
him I can't be mad at it
well yeah because when I saw the eight
to one I was like you know yeah I I if
you're wondering why I voted that way it
was because I did not want to be on the
wrong side of the vote and people
weren't telling me where they were
voting because they didn't know if they
could during the commercial break and I
was like all right well let's see I
don't want to be the bitty juror who has
a unanimous vote for Monty and then
votes for Taylor Just because he voted
me out so I think Monty might win
because he had a history of winning
comps and people liked him and so I
guess I'll vote for Monty and it went
the exact opposite way and by no means
by voting against Taylor I love Taylor
one of the nice people I've met in my
entire life so I wasn't a phone again
sailor just voted for my boy Monty and I
had like five seconds to think about it
and gave the worst speech ever when
putting in my key so I just went with it
do you think the new showmance that was
going on had something to do with it
um that was my concern I I feel like I
am almost the equivalent of Nicole in 21
where she was going up against
um Jackson and Jackson and Holly like
yeah you're going up against the show
man it's like what the hell else is
going to happen and I totally get that
love is in the air in the Big Brother
house and as Taylor always said she
lives in a sexless ass house and that
was true until it wasn't so I hope their
love is fruitful on the outside and um
Monty said he's gonna do van life all
inspired by me so I am excited to see
where his journey takes him
well yeah it clouds the mind you know
love clouds of wine oh that it does and
I was just able to see my amazing
girlfriend Megan who I have heard is a
hit on online so the first thing Pooch
when I when I reignited my my favorite
person in the house
um two weeks with him I love Pooch so
much one of the coolest people I've ever
met um if he was in the house longer I
think he would have made the craziest
impact because he was just so chaotic
the first thing he said to me was I love
Megan and I was like me too I had a I
had a time with my girlfriend for about
20 minutes and I was stuck back into
this portal but I'm happy to be here and
um I don't even remember what I'm
answering but there we go
all right if we were to put a Taylor
Super Bowl commercial for potato chips
what do you think that would look like
let's see well all right Taylor and
Rihanna walk into the halftime show no
one's there yet Taylor takes a bite of a
potato chip and then a million cheers
all the lights go on it's Taylor and
Rihanna and then you see a big logo it
says
um Lays potato chips and then Taylor
makes a bite and then some remarks she
says when the logo title comes up and
then there's a Rihanna song in the
background there you go of everybody I
asked this question you gave the best
response one thousand percent you win
the 750 for that response oh okay well
yeah uh lays I bet if they hire someone
for a Super Bowl ad maybe they make 750
so let's go I feel like we're there's
some synergies going on here we're
making a marketing connection oh I'm
with it I do I have an incredible idea
for a Mazda ad where someone's eating
pasta in a Mazda so if anyone can use
that either then there you go I feel
like we could do something with a muffin
with you as well oh my god dude and I
have a dog named the muffin he can be in
it
okay that just like it's too perfect
that's what I'm saying dude and I I did
hear that the muffin Saga was online
from my dad and apparently that made the
episodes obviously I don't know I made
the episodes but I'm glad if I have any
Legacy in Big Brother it is the muffin
yeah you're in the muffin man
essentially oh my God yes you know him
it's me no I guess you know him now
all right so I've asked this to the rest
of the cast mates
um you're busting And discussing amazing
everyone loves these terms so I'm gonna
let's go ask you uh different Big
Brother moments and you're going to tell
me if you think they're blessing or
disgusting or you could say mid yeah
absolutely all right all right let's go
living in the Big Brother house oh
absolutely Boston once in a lifetime
experience that I will never forget and
if I'm ever called back I will be there
again and it'll be awesome
all right the BB comic
oh my BB comic
that thing was so disgusting I don't
know what why they think I look like
that but at the end of the day it is so
chaotic and iconic and just so crazy
looking that it is busting so so
disgusting it became busted
all right the zingbog things
The Zing bot Zing oh my God that I I
don't listen this is all because of
Pooch because early on he saw where I
was putting my laundry and it just
happened to be in a big pile in the
corner of the room and he was like bro
do you ever he was like Bro Look At Me
Do you have a shower and I'm like oh my
God yes I shower every other day but
everyone else in the house showers like
four times a day I'm like where'd you
guys find the freaking time so I shower
every other day and I will die on that
hill and um my zing buzzing was
disgusting because I am a clean person
your Pooja accent was really big on the
back there that was pretty good and you
always stood like this I don't know why
but all the time so I'm glad you like
that
all right meeting Julie oh my God that
was bus and she I I met her I guess in
person twice before we walked in and I
didn't really say much to her but that
like I felt like I was watching a movie
through my own eyes when I walked out of
that house
um since the first episode I ever saw of
Big Brother in uh 2019 I remember people
would walk out and I was like if I walk
out I'm gonna do some crowd control I'm
gonna put my hands up in the air and
make some cheers and that's what I did
and I feel like if anything my lifelong
dream since 2019 not necessarily the
lifelong of doing that happened and I
could not be happier
um I love that for you okay now Daniel's
freak out oh my God Daniel's freak out
combined with right after he freaked out
me asleep in the HOH room and him
busting in and being like bro I gotta
tell you I just yelled at Taylor and I'm
like first off I don't care whatever bad
decisions you made in this house and
second off I'm asleep so could you we
just let me finish this map but how
chaotic Daniel I am just dying to see
how Daniel is perceived outside of this
house because like the freak out on
Taylor was disgusted dude just let the
girl live people would get mad no matter
what Taylor did and so I'm glad I again
I don't know what is shown because I
haven't seen the season but I'm glad if
anything happened uh week three I was
able to stick up for Taylor I think I
was on the the right side of Taylor most
of the time I did nominate her a few
weeks later and for stumbling into that
decision I don't know why well I guess I
know why but whatever
um but yeah no anyone freaking out at
Taylor discussing just everyone relax
Taylor is an amazing person oh well
thank you so much I love how we have the
same ombre going on I don't have as much
of a contrast but I I yes no I I this
well I had it all blonde at one point
and I was like I checked out at the
salon I was like this is 250 to go
blonde so I was like I am not going back
oh whatever I'm letting it grow and
everyone's your hair I know right now I
think it's more unique so I am obsessed
with what I have going on now I'm the
same with you I'm growing on my blonde
and I'm just going to be back to my
roots I think I think you should go as
long as I did and then we could be the
only people on planet Earth aside from
Billy eilish who has ever looked like
this
oh amazing it was so nice chatting with
you and it was so fun watching you the
whole season you were such a character
and uh I hope you enjoy the night
getting back together yeah absolutely
it's been a pleasure you are an
incredible interviewer and I applaud you
for your skills in that field clearly
you're doing something right because
this was a lot wow thank you you're so
sweet have a great rest of the night